[Musique]
bonsoir vous avez déjà été mis dans une
case vous on vous a déjà dit que vous
étiez écolo zéro déchet minimaliste
déconnecté ou décroissant plus extrême
encore rétrograde ou archaïque
peut-être qu'à l'envers si vous êtes
moderne vous rechercher l'efficacité
vous êtes progressiste performant high
tech évolutionniste ces cases rassure
tout le monde
ça nous donne des repères des valeurs
des chemins pour avancer dans le flot de
complexité qui nous entoure mais dans
ces cases où sont l'amour le partage la
poésie la vie tout simplement la vie
dans laquelle on s'épanouit
personnellement où l'on vit en communion
où l'on a des moments d'harmonie et de
joie il y à quelques temps mon métier
c'était de transmettre des savoirs sur
des technologies plus respectueuses
utile accessible et durable elle porte
en elle l'espoir d'un avenir plus en
accord avec notre environnement
vous savez le compost les chauffages
solaires les toilettes sèches et j'en
passe alors oui j'ai été catalogué écolo
zéro déchet minimaliste déconnecté mais
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que j'ai pu le droit
d'aller dans des toilettes normal que
j'ai plus droit d'avoir un mac de
prendre l'avion d'acheter des aliments
emballés dans du plastique
face à toutes ces injonctions trier
mieux la planète restera bleus manger
bio et local c'est idéal ne file est
plus un mauvais coton suivez la fibre
éthiques j'ai constamment l'impression
d'être en porte à faux
enfermé même et vous vous sentez pas
culpabiliser impuissant en situation de
rejet
j'entends des gens qui disent ça sert à
rien on peut pas changer les choses à
soi tout seul
des gens qui se confrontent comme moi à
une grosse désillusion et à une baisse
de moral parce qu'on est incapable de
corréler nos actions avec ce qu'on
attend de nous j'ai le sentiment qu'on
construit des individus écartelé qu'on
arrive à une société complètement cliver
et à une déresponsabilisation citoyenne
dramatique et la liberté dans tout ça
l'épanouissement personnel la poésie bas
stop stop aux cases et si la réponse
c'était ailleurs si la réponse c'était
de porter un autre regard sur les autres
les choses notre façon de faire notre
façon d'être un regard poétique un
regard esthétique
libéré de toutes ses injonctions
c'est ça qui serait vivre vivre
poétiquement vivre tout simplement
alors prenons le temps de nous attarder
sur un style vestimentaire un bâtiment
un tableau un intérieur nos yeux en
épousant la beauté d'une robe d'un
jardin d'une démarche nous font voyager
dans une autre vision du monde vers une
autre vie possible vers d'autres valeurs
l'autre jour je cherchais une cafetière
je suis tombé sur une cafetière à piston
vous voyez j'aurais pu l'acheter parce
que c'était la plus écologique
ben j'ai simplement pensé qu'elle était
plus belle qu'une cafetière électrique
quand j'ai compris que j'aime et acheter
un livre d'occasion pas par conviction
mais parce qu'il porte en lui une
histoire le ressenti d'un autre être
humain
alors j'ai compris j'ai compris que
regarder les choses les gens les gestes
qui m'entourent à travers la poésie et
l'esthétique m'a apporté de la joie de
la sérénité et de l'harmonie s'ouvrir à
l'art et à l'esthétique m'a permis de
regarder autrement et de me contenter de
peu de construire un quotidien plus
léger plus aérée débarrassé de la charge
mentale du tu dois être un site tu dois
faire comme ça j'aborde mes gestes
quotidiens comme manger boire dormir non
plus de façon banale ou culpabiliser
mais de façon poétique dormir c'est plus
récupérer de l'énergie pour aller
travailler dormir
c'est rêver il y en a parmi vous qui
vont marcher c'est beau c'est vivant non
ça vous donne pas envie d'aimer et de
respecter ces aliments et les gens qui
les cultivent avec tout ça j'ai plus
besoin de compenser mon inconfort par
une consommation excessive ou par des
gestes inutiles jeu simply mon quotidien
mais je ne simplifie pas ma pensée ni ma
vision du monde
bien au contraire je n'aborde plus aucun
de mes gestes comme la conséquence d'une
injonction sociale mais comme la
recherche d'un art de vivre
alors c'est quoi le message là demain
devenons tous poètes pour sortir des
cases non demain regardons chaque chose
avec un regard aussi libéré que celui
que nous portons sur l'art sur le beau
sur l'esthétique par l'art on a encore
la liberté la liberté d'aimer de
questionner de rejeter même le plaisir
esthétique nous sort de nos boîtes de
non culpabilité
il pose des questions à l'extérieur de
tout ce capharnaüm
il ouvre de nouvelles portes penser et
faire pas par conviction écologique par
modernisme par efficacité mais par
plaisir esthétique m'a permis de
transcender toutes ses cales mais
attention je ne renie en rien ses
convictions je les ai simplement aborder
par une autre porte et en ouvrant cette
forte
j'ai découvert que l'art permettait de
communiquer autrement de façon moins
injonctive plus globale il ne communique
pas un message il transmet une pensée
une émotion un vécu c'est une forme de
transmission universelle qui questionne
au lieu d'ordonner je vous invite à
regarder ou à re regardé le tableau
guernica de picasso
moi je n'ai jamais aussi bien compris la
guerre et la violence qu'à travers lui
je n'ai jamais aussi bien compris la
richesse des peuples premiers qu'à
travers les dessins des grottes de
lascaux et si je dois transmettre à mon
tour je suis bien incapable de
transmettre un message sans le magnifier
houle esthétisé transmettre une émotion
c'est le meilleur moyen de donner envie
à quelqu'un de s'intéresser de se
questionner sur un propos si je vous
montre aujourd'hui que mettre un
composteur chez vous c'est plus beau
c'est plus poétique qu'une poubelle ne
serez vous pas plus convaincu que si je
vous ordonne de le faire pour protéger
la planète
les artistes dans toutes les
civilisations ont toujours été
considérés comme des éclaireurs qui nous
montre des voies à suivre
pensons à charlie chaplin dans les temps
modernes qui remet en question notre
société de consommation à travers des
histoires ou encore à léonard de vinci
qui à travers ses peintures et ses
dessins imaginaire à léguer aux
générations futures la roue à aubes les
machines volantes
le sous marin et jusqu'à la
concentration de l'énergie solaire ses
rêves font aujourd'hui partie intégrante
de notre quotidien
ils sont même le symbole de notre
modernité
alors oui servons nous de là pour
expliquer questionner témoignée par les
sens et par la pratique par
l'enchantement visuelle sonore tactile
et non comme on le fait souvent par la
théorie
passons à une transmission par le vécu
parce qu'elle apporte une réponse à
notre quête de bien vivre parce qu'elle
est à notre portée parce qu'elle permet
de se coucher en accord avec soi-même et
parce que toutes les civilisations ont
toujours utilisé là pour questionner
leur temps je vous dis ça mais je suis
persuadé que ce regard vous l'avez déjà
je suis même persuadé que vous le
pratiquez souvent dans votre quotidien
la seule différence c'est qu'il est
peut-être encore cantonnée à un moment
ou à une situation précise lorsque vous
admirer la beauté d'un paysage dans un
film ou que vous vous délectez de la
poésie d'un livre vous y êtes déjà pour
moi le moment qui symbolise le mieux ce
regard c'est le moment du voyage
le voyage avec un grand v ça parle à
certains d'entre vous que ce soit loin
ou prêts longs ou courts
peu importe vous remplissez votre sac le
moins possible non en partant vous
réduisez votre confort quotidien à
l'essentiel et vous ouvrez votre regard
vous regardez tout ce qui vous entoure
avec plus de curiosité de questions de
poésie un vélo amsterdam ou un souk au
maroc devient quelque chose
d'extraordinaire d'intenses aimant
poétique et vivant en vous confrontant à
la différence de culture vous
enrichissez votre vision du monde mais
vous ne demandez rien en échange vous
profiter simplement de cette nouvelle
beauté vous recherchez la symbiose avec
ce nouvel environnement
le contact le partage alors ne quant au
non plus ce regard un film un livre ou
un voyage
appliquons le à notre quotidien c'est le
meilleur moyen de se laisser toutes les
portes ouvertes à l'image du voyage
la frugalité permet d'aller vers une vie
collective plus simple plus belle avec
plus de temps de partage humain moins de
travail et plus de rêve à accomplir
en plus ça me laisse espérer
que des solutions au désordre social
peuvent apparaître
alors si vous aussi
contrairement à toutes ces cases il
n'est pas nécessaire d'être
irréprochable pour s'engager dans cette
voie
si vous aussi vous partagez cette
simplicité de regard il est grand temps
de la vivre et surtout je vous encourage
à la transmettre
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]